all right it has been an insane day at
9:30 we had the William bar propaganda
press conference which lasted about 20
minutes which I'll talk about a little
bit we already talked about it sort of
on today's broadcast show and then we
had the release of the redacted version
of the Moller report 400 ish pages I
think the PDF is actually closer to 450
pages and there is just so much to go
through it's hard to know where to start
I am going to be looking at different
things that are in the molar report but
I've not gone through every page so far
I've read a whole bunch of it skimmed
through part of it read pieces written
about the molar report and we've just
been doing the best we can to sort of
keep up with what's going on so if there
are particular elements of it that you
want me to look at I'm also glad to
we'll talk about people that have
admitted to lying when they spoke to the
special counsel including Sarah Huckabee
Sanders we will talk about the reasons
that Robert Muller gave for not charging
Donald Trump with obstruction all of
which were not all of which I will say
most of which were political reasons in
nature which is extraordinarily
disturbing so all of this and much more
of which we will be talking about today
I will remind you that the press
conference itself really warrants
coverage of its own William bars press
conference but then with the Moller
report coming out a lot of the focus is
there but William bar gave an
extraordinarily political I mean what
one that this did not appear to be a
Justice Department official this
appeared to be one of trumps attorneys
talking about how Donald Trump was
targeted and and framing Donald Trump as
the victim and the person who really has
been victimized here despite the fact
that the molar report points out that
there was significant evidence
significant evidence of intent to
obstruct and of obstruction by Donald
Trump all of which we will be getting to
and it is you sort of have to hand it to
them and in my commentary on the
broadcast show tomorrow about this I'm
going to say it again they did it right
it's you had a very well executed and I
get it partially it's well executed
because trumpets are so gullible
but listen you execute what you need to
on the basis of who you need to convince
and trumpets have fallen hook line and
sinker for the bar letter which sort of
primed the pump for people to say no
indictment of Trump well then there's
nothing to see here when of course that
was never the standard to begin with the
press conference this morning
further propagandizing and then they
don't read a 448 page reports so you've
got to hand it to trump and more likely
the people around him who have been able
to effectively manage this as a public
relations incident as a public relations
event to the benefit of the president
and you know I don't like it I think
it's disgusting but this is bars area of
expertise he's covered it up he's
covered up for prior presidents and he
was brought in to do the job and he did
it I don't know what his I don't
remember offhand what the cabinet
salaries are maybe it's 175,000 or 225 I
don't remember a bargain I mean truly a
bargain for what Donald Trump has gotten
from William bar and we'll talk more
about the the bar press conference if
people want me through but I want to
focus in on the report so as we get into
it here this is a live stream this is
different than the clips that we
typically upload in that they are live
meaning that you can participate the
best way to participate in the live
streams is using the super chat function
that's the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window when you send a super
chat it will pop up on the screen and
then I will read it and I will react to
it if it's a question I'll answer it if
it's a comment I will give my thoughts
sign up for memberships if you want to
call in if people want to talk about the
molar report or anything else on the
phones if you want to call me sign up
for a membership on our website david
pakman.com slash membership there are
discount codes down below and if you
want to call in include your area code
in the first or last name field in
addition to your name when you sign up
so that way i'll
you priority if and when we open up the
phone lines if you just want the phone
lines to be opened and you're not so
into calling then no big deal
we are looking for 10 new members on our
website and that will get the phone
lines open
please don't troll the live chat we have
more moderators than ever monitoring the
live chat and if you troll you will be
timed out or banned because
bands are free and we're trying to run a
tight ship here and lastly you can also
use the join button down below which
will allow you to sign up for a
membership on YouTube those count
towards the target of 10 but YouTube
does take 30% of your YouTube membership
whereas on our website we pay just a 2.9
percent
processing fee so let's get over to the
report first and foremost here and as I
mentioned 448 pages there is a lot here
that we could look at and if you have
specific pages that you want me to look
at let me know in the super chat please
refer to them now that's a good question
do I want you to refer to them by the
page as numbered on the report or do I
want you to refer to it as the page of
the PDF I don't know just tell me PDF
page or report page so that I can more
easily identify them this was a redacted
version of the report and as people saw
if they looked at it some pages mildly
redacted some pages if we scroll further
down very very significantly redacted as
you get down into the pages number 20
and later more and more redactions to
the point where some pages you see only
the citation I paid whatever page this
is 17 all that is not redacted are two
of the however many there are here eight
footnotes or whatever and otherwise this
one sentence otherwise completely
redacted and what is really important to
take away from the redactions in
addition to the fact that we're not
getting a lot of the material on a lot
of these issues and pages is that if we
believe this redaction reason that's
cited which says harm to ongoing matter
what that tells us is that not redacting
these portions would potentially damage
going matters this is understood to mean
between 12 and 14 referred cases which
are continually which continue to be
active and for everybody you know we can
debate there won't be any more
indictments there will be more
indictments we don't know the answer to
that what we do know is that the molar
Grand Jury continues to operate and 12
to 14 minimum additional investigations
are still going on here and that is what
it means when something is redacted for
the reason of harm to ongoing matter
that could also be alive right so this
is assuming that this is the correct and
accurate reason why these redactions
have taken place let's look at a couple
different things one of the issues that
has come up a time and again is that of
whether the Special Counsel was able to
identify intent in Donald Trump's
actions that could have or were meant to
obstruct the investigation we'll get
later to this issue of underlying crimes
but what's really important to
understand is that the report does
discuss intent and it discusses it in a
number of different places one notable
place I forget exactly which page this
is actually has a subsection C called
intent and it says substantial evidence
substantial evidence substantial
evidence really important to understand
when people are saying no evidence the
report says substantial evidence
indicates that the president's effort
this is just one example to have Jeff
Sessions limit the scope of the special
counsels investigation to future
election interference was intended to
further prevent investigative scrutiny
of the president's and his campaigns
conduct you might have forgotten that
this even took place let me remind you
what this was even about there was a
moment before Jeff Sessions recused
himself from anything Russia related
which of course was the right move since
he had lied about his personal contacts
with Russians who's remembering that at
this point there was a moment where
Trump wanted Jeff sessions to restrict
the investigation and say okay Moeller
can do his investigation the
investigation can take place but it has
to be only about future election
interference and preventing interference
at some point in the future
Trump was so disconnected from the
reality of what this probe was about
that he actually went to Jeff sessions
and he wanted the probe rather than
obviously being about what Trump did and
what the campaign did and what took
place in the lead-up to and during
Trump's administration Trump had the
bright idea of telling Jeff sessions
focused the investigation in only on the
future possible interference and of
course this is one of the many sections
in the probe report which says no we
have identified the investigators
identified that Donald Trump's
motivation in other words his intent was
to prevent a full investigation into
what he had done this is intent to
obstruct that's it and this is just one
example and there are many more Sarah
Huckabee Sanders let's see if I can get
this framed properly for you one of the
other revelations and again I'm going
through some of these things piecemeal
because there are 450 pages to this
thing and I've only had time to look at
some of it if you have something
specific you want me to pull up in the
report in your super chat tell me what
page you want me to look at and we can
look at it together
Sarah Huckabee Sanders admitted to the
Special Counsel that she lied about
James Comey she's claiming that these
were slips of the tongue but we have
some of the video and I think it's very
hard to believe that you'll notice here
that this Mother Jones article explains
after a reporter claimed that a vast
majority of agents supported James Comey
hukka Sarah Huckabee Sanders replied
look we've heard from countless members
of the FBI that say different very
different things let's take a look at
some of this video and let me make sure
we're set up to actually hear it
- such confidence that rank-and-file
within the bureau lost faith the FBI
directive is a special agent who is
inside he wrote us who said the vast
majority of the Bureau is in favor of
director Comey this is a total shock
this is not supposed to happen the real
losers here are 20,000 frontline people
in the organization because they lost
the only guy working here in the past 15
years who actually cared about them so
what's your response to these
rank-and-file of FBI agents who who
disagree with your contention that they
lost faith in direct occult look we've
heard from countless members of the FBI
that say very different things in fact
the president will be meeting with
Acting Director mccabe later today to
discuss that very thing the morale at
the FBI as well as make an offer to go
directly to the FBI if he feels that
that's necessary in a ok so that as this
is indicated that response was not
founded on anything molars office
concluded after interviewing Sanders who
told Special Counsel staffers she made a
slip of the tongue then a slip of the
tongue a slip of the tongue is you know
if I want to say Mitch McConnell and I
say [ __ ] McConnell a slip of the tongue
is if I'm referring to Fox News reporter
Steve Doocy
and I slip and I say Steve douchey for
example those are slips of the tongue
responding to a question by saying we've
heard from countless FBI agents who
support the President of the United
States or however it was that she worded
it that's not a slip of the tongue
that's just a lie okay so many of you
will say David she lies every day every
every day that she speaks to the press
corps Sarah Huckabee Sanders is lying
yes we knew that we inferred that we had
that belief already but we now have a
special prosecutor who determined that
when it came down to it Sarah Huckabee
Sanders told the truth and she admitted
that wasn't true she just made that up
just one example of the many people who
have been identified as having been
liars
by the special counsels report now let's
continue here Muller report Trump tried
to get special counsel fired there are a
bunch of different revelations which
this BBC article
reveals and we will look at a couple of
them here mr. Trump reportedly used an
expletive when the investigation was
announced adding oh my god this is
terrible this is the end of my
presidency
not mentioned there is that he also said
I'm [ __ ] now if you believe that the
investigation is going to clear you you
wouldn't ordinarily say that right and I
know that people on Twitter are
defending this by saying no Trump didn't
think he was [ __ ] because he believed
he had done anything
Trump believed he was [ __ ] because
people told him that special counsels
destroy a presidency and prevent you
from being able to do anything okay
that's the most charitable strongest
defense of this but when you continue to
look at the special counsel and the
things that report and the things that
Donald Trump said you very quickly
develop a picture of someone who doesn't
believe that they're going to have a
problem merely because there is an
investigation but rather because of what
the investigation is going to find and
we'll get to some of those examples
later robert muller examined ten actions
by the president in regards to
obstruction of justice which he said
largely took place in public view the
report says that potential obstruction
of justice by the president only failed
because members of his administration
including former FBI director james
comey refused to carry out orders these
two bullet points are extraordinarily
important because robert muller and i
don't have the page number in front of
me of robert muller explained that the
reasons he decided not to charge donald
trump with obstruction were number one
that he in some attempts failed to
actually obstruct because members of his
administration refused to go along with
what he said because some of the
attempts at obstructing it took place in
public view which criminally speaking
doesn't matter legally speaking
shouldn't matter and number three
because robert muller believed that
charging the president with obstruction
would significantly significantly hinder
or impair his ability to carry out his
duties as president that's a political
reason okay that's a political reason
not to charge the president that is
separate from the evidence and that's a
theme of this report that there was
plenty of evidence of wrongdoing by a
whole bunch of different people but
politically motivated reasons were made
not to bring charges
investigators viewed the president's
written responses to their questions as
inadequate but chose not to pursue a
potentially lengthy legal battle to
interview him if you ask me what are the
most depressing elements of this report
this bullet point is part of that and I
want to get to that element next okay I
said this at the beginning and I have to
say it again and by the way I see that
there are a whole bunch of super chats
coming up and please keep sending them
with elements you want me to look at I
will get to those one by one and if you
want to call in about this stuff I'll
open the phone lines if we get 10 new
members okay and then you can call in
and talk to me about this or anything
else sign up on our website david
pakman.com slash membership I see new
memberships coming in and I see super
chats coming in and I will get to that
but I don't want to interrupt what we're
discussing here everybody I'm hesitating
use the term everybody but almost
everybody understands that Donald Trump
physically sitting down with Robert
Moeller or his investigators would have
been disastrous for Trump Trump lies
uncontrollably Trump also seems to not
sometimes know that people can tell that
he is lying he thinks he's an
extraordinarily good liar maybe part of
it's related to cognitive decline we
don't know okay
but Trump sitting down with
investigators would have been a disaster
and one of the biggest achievements of
Donald Trump's legal team in this entire
thing and hats off to them is that they
convinced Robert Muller
to accept the submission of written
questions and then written answers back
to Robert Muller and we now have those
answers and one of the most disgusting
elements of this entire thing is that as
the report says investigators did not
find those written answers adequate but
they didn't pursue it because of the
lengthy legal battle that would have
ensued this is once again a decision
made on political expediency right it
would have been a mess legally to force
Donald Trump to come in and sit down and
look at the answers that Donald Trump
got away with giving these are a whole
bunch of the questions that were asked
so section I about the meeting at Trump
Tower when did you first learn that
junior and man afford Kushner were
considering this meeting did Don junior
tell you about the communications he was
having but really specific questions
really key stuff okay if we scroll down
here a bit and you can look at the full
list of questions you will see that
Donald Trump's answers are that he just
doesn't remember anything
Donald Trump who has claimed to have one
of the greatest memories period right
one of the greatest memories of all time
of all Americans who knows how he
phrased it I have no recollection of
learning at the time that Don junior
Paul or Jared were considering having
this meeting he just doesn't remember
best memory of all time doesn't remember
question one Part D I have no
independent recollection of what portion
of these four days in June of 2016 I
spent in Trump Tower this was related to
trying to figure out if Trump was in the
building when the meeting with the
Russian lawyer took place what you know
my Trump Organization calendar reflects
that I was outside Trump Tower okay I
have no independent recollection of any
communications I had with the aguillera
family or anyone I understood to be
representing them I do not recall being
aware of the campaign of communications
between Don jr. Paul Manafort or Jared
Kushner and members of the aguillera
family or Robert Goldstone or the
Russian lawyer Netanyahu Natalia
bassinets kiya whose name I was not
familiar with at the time or anyone
understood to be a Russian official what
else do we have examples of this I have
no recollection of being told during the
campaign that Putin or the Russian
government supported my candidacy or
opposed the candidacy of Hillary Clinton
but I was aware of reports indicating
that Putin had made complimentary
statements about me who believes that
garbage who believes that Donald Trump
can't remember any point during the
campaign given all of the hundred-plus
context that were going on that somebody
mentioned to him hey Brett
Russia Russia has a favorable view that
Russia supports your Russia doesn't want
Hillary to win and if he had no
recollection of that why did he say why
did he think it would have been a
reasonable request to ask that Russia
hack Hillary's emails unbelievable
completely unbelievable but he got away
with it I have no recollection of being
told during the campaign that any
foreign government or foreign leader had
provided wish to provide or offer to
provide tangible support to my campaign
the guy with the best memory of any kind
doesn't remember excuse me punching my
mic there and I apologize
he doesn't remember a damn thing so no
sane person no rational person
no remotely informed person would
believe that Donald from both has the
best memory or a good memory
he just can't remember a damn thing he
doesn't remember anything from the
campaign and who does he have to thank
for this his attorneys who negotiated
for month after month after month and
Gottemoeller to agree to just accept
written answers from Donald Trump I mean
these attorney if I if I take an
agnostic view about what's better for
the country knowing what happened or not
knowing what happened or people being
held accountable or not as attorneys
they did an extraordinarily good job
wonder if they got paid because we know
Trump often doesn't pay his bills let's
look at a couple of other things well
maybe we'll pause here let's pause here
and then let me do some new member
thank-yous and get to some super chats
so I'll open the phone lines at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 I see a lot of people
commenting in the chat that they want to
call in I will open the phone lines as
soon as we get 10 new members on our
website
Jason Ford is this evening's first new
member Jason Ford signing up using the
coupon code this is 2020 that saves him
40% off of his membership let me make
you sort of an offer if you want to be
one of the first people to call in when
you sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership in the first or last name
field in addition to your name put your
area code I will make a note of it on a
piece of paper that
right in front of me with this pen and
then when we open the phone lines I'll
go to you first okay so if you want to
talk to me be one of the next nine
people to sign up include your area code
and then we'll get you a priority on the
phone lines to coupon codes are
available this is 20/20 saves you 40%
off of any membership save thirty five
will only work on the $60 a year
membership and it'll drop it to just
twenty five bucks which I have to tell
you is is a damn good deal it is a very
very good deal okay let's check out some
super chats there are a lot of people
with comments and questions about what
is going on here let's see this is from
a different day but G Byrne says your
video on misdemeanors and systemic
criminal justice discrepancies due to
poverty is excellent thank you very much
a Britney Michelle became a YouTube
member I guess this is earlier today we
had a dollar super chat that was
retracted the political one asks Vegeta
does the scouter say about his power
level its over 9000 hey David do you
think Trump has authoritarian tendencies
if yes what are they yes he does he has
tendencies towards being an autocrat he
has tendencies towards a restricting
press freedom by suggesting opening up
libel lawsuits and journalism licenses
and all this stuff he said he thought
the idea of what China did allowing
president-for-life
was interesting and maybe we would try
it that's fundamentally against the sort
of democratic founding principles of the
United States so there are many and by
the way I know it's not veggie de I just
like to pretend I don't know what's
going on Alphonso Saldana says check out
move to amend.org and endorse us maybe
thanks yeah isn't moved to amend
John Boniface's organization I know John
from Western Mass and sat next to him on
a flight back from DC once actually show
SOI baboso says Bernie went ultra
instinct in the Fox News townhall yeah
he crushed it check out my analysis of
the Fox News townhall horror fan for
life says great live cast David Trump is
the deep state okay
G says DPM I have no idea what that
means
James Buchi nose says have any other
presidents been as corrupt as Trump I
don't know that we'll know yet I think
you you don't really get perspective on
a lot of this stuff until a little time
goes by but he's certainly up there
horror fan for life says David huge fan
and want to call in sometime have a lot
to say I ask this because I'm a lifelong
stutterer and it's been making me a
little nervous okay well we've had
stutterers call-in before and I don't
know I don't know what else to say I
don't know that much about stuttering
interestingly enough f RBE Oh 101 says I
give you money monthly via your website
but I only listen to you via YouTube
what other ways can I listen well we've
got a podcast which is available on
Spotify Pandora iHeartRadio stitcher
iTunes and also on our web site and you
can add it to any podcast feed that you
have we're on nearly 200 radio and
television stations the show is on free
speech TV which is on DirecTV and Dish
Network nightly so many other ways to
listen and we have a Members Only
commercial free audio and video feed
which you can access by going to the
member content section of our website
which as you can see is up here in the
menu area it only displays if you have
an active membership otherwise it is
hidden from view few ways that you can
do it in credit bow TV it scrolled up
here we go I've been a member for a
month and it's the shiznit
if you ain't rocking with Pakman then
that's sad Trump Voice sign up ASAP F ad
pocalypse 2.0 yes F ad pocalypse 2.0 and
in fact Greyson Smith has just signed up
on our website Greyson Smith is the
newest member he is not taking any
coupon code discounts paying the full
rate Greyson really appreciate it that's
new member number two eight to go and
I'll open up the phone lines Kripa nipa
says no money to travel to Washington to
protest was this the plan what listen I
mean if your general so yes generally
there is this
dynamic where we hear that all sorts of
people are saying that if X happens or
if Y happens they will descend on
Washington DC or wherever and they will
protest the reality is people are busy
right wage stagnation growing income
inequality difficult to afford health
care
difficult to afford cost of living its
way to stay the same and cost of living
goes up so when the rubber meets the
road a lot of people just can't take
time off from work and and go protest
and that's something we've addressed
before adjacent Brown 12 says hey David
what do you think of the jbp versus Z
Zack jiseok I forget how to pronounce
the last name I heard that they would be
debating has it happened or do you mean
what do I think of the idea if it hasn't
happened yet
I'd be sort of curious about Jordan
Peterson versus Zack buy my you know
they both have Jordan Peterson's way of
debating is very it includes a lot of
sort of tangential thinking and he can
be sort of difficult to follow and then
Zzyzx way of thinking and speaking is
completely tangential so I hope that
they don't spend two hours introducing
themselves and arguing about the right
way to introduce themselves and not get
to anything because they both are liable
to do that biz Wiz says the report
didn't exonerate Trump from obstruction
in fact it did quite the opposite what
the hell are our legislative leaders
going to do about it probably nothing
probably nothing sadly and that is part
of why I am praising Trump's lawyers
have have as having managed this in an
extraordinarily smart way because there
were there will probably be no
consequences
Alex Malone says I have a question for
the main show can I send a voicemail
from 6 1 0 yeah I mean you can submit
questions any number of ways for the
regular show and voicemail is one of
those ways enter name sends a $5 super
chat and then another $5
super chat with the question what's your
thought on 2020 Democratic candidate
very very clever you think I don't watch
Howard Stern listen to Howard Stern
Lakers fan will Trump [ __ ] you almost
got me there
you really did almost got me there
Lakers fan will Trump chicken out of the
debates if Bernie is the nominee no he
will not
no he will not James Buchi no do you
know when the Pakman show live in Boston
is yeah we're looking at doing a live
event here in Boston we are currently in
the process of reaching out to possible
guests for the interview portion and we
are trying to figure that out in
conjunction with the date we have a
location that will work so no
announcement yet James but I will I will
let you know when I know more about it
it may well end up being limited to 50
people for two reasons one there's a
really great space that we like and is
well located but it only has room for 50
60 and we need like 10 for our staff and
the event staff and the guests and their
staff and that type of thing so we may
only we were initially thinking of it as
like a hundred and fifty person venue
but it might be limited to 50 in which
case we'd have to think about how we're
gonna manage ticket sales and that type
of thing but I will let you know as soon
as I have more information about it okay
we have a third new member that I want
to welcome Brian Molina Brian Molina
signing up at full price but you don't
have to sign up at full price we now
have three new members if seven more
people sign up I will open up the phone
lines I'm noticing that all sorts of
voicemails are coming in right now on
the phone line which is six one seven
eight three zero 47 50 the phone line is
not yet open the phone line is six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
but it won't be open until we get ten
new members which means three more
memberships are not a lot of money and
we really do a lot of stuff for our
members including the members only
newsletter the members only bonus show
which is daily the Members Only
commercial
audio stream of the show the members
only commercial free video stream of the
show and if you apply the coupon code
save 35 to the $60 a year membership
it's just 25 bucks for the year okay
it's $2 in 8 cents a month is what it
works out to it's not a lot of money and
with the continued issues with YouTube D
monetizing a bunch of our videos it
really makes a big big difference for
our funding source to have these
memberships and that's why I'm thrilled
that Jason Ford signed up tonight and
Greyson smith signed up tonight and
brian molina signed up and as an extra
incentive if you include your area code
when you sign up in addition to your
name in either the first or last name
field I will make a note of your area
code down here and when we open the
phone lines you can talk to me first
just as an extra incentive to get people
signing up because it is a really big
thing and an important thing for us okay
there's a couple other things I wanted
to talk about related to the molar
report well that is very zoomed in Chuck
Todd had a commentary that Donald Trump
and William Barr successfully neutered
the impact of the Malloy report and I
couldn't agree with him more this is one
of the points I made today on the
broadcast show in which I will follow up
on tomorrow during the broadcast show
NBC meet the press moderator Chuck Todd
on Thursday said Trump and Barr
successfully neutered the impact of the
Moller report politically by their
actions in the weeks following the
reports conclusions
Todd said the political implications of
the report would have been very
different if bar simply released the
statement saying there were no
recommendations for criminal charges and
if he said I'm looking into everything
regarding how this investigation started
the investigation itself and all those
things period had he said all those
things without using buzzwords without
doing a press conference without writing
a summary without making a decision on
his own and taking matters into his own
hands we'd have a different conversation
right now and we'd have a much different
interpretation of Bill Bar as Attorney
General the president and Bill Barr has
have successfully neutered the impact of
the molar report politically that's the
bottom line absolutely spot-on I don't
really ever watch Chuck Todd and when I
have I've not been super impressed with
what he says but I've been making this
case for a while now the installation I
would actually go back to the selection
of Matthew Whitaker on an interim basis
followed by the installation of William
bar followed by the letter followed by
everything else that we saw it has been
carried out perfectly perfectly
perfectly perfectly and this is why more
than likely even though the report as
we've been talking about has substantial
found substantial evidence of corruption
found all sorts of concerning material
found all sorts of liars found all sorts
of people who had the intent to obstruct
the investigation it will probably end
up with almost no political impact
whatsoever no legal impact whatsoever
the political impact question will be
left for November of 2022 people voting
very interesting article on The Daily
Beast let's see if we can zoom out a
little bit here the crazy zoom I don't
know why it happens here we go
a bunch of different highlights that The
Daily Beast found the Trump I'm [ __ ]
moment is quite notable Donald Trump
when he found out that the investigation
was taking place claimed that he
believed it was the end of his
presidency asking Jeff Sessions how
could you let this happen everyone tells
me if you get one of these independent
counsels it ruins at your presidency it
takes years and years and I won't be
able to do anything this is the worst
thing that ever happened to me Trump
screamed I don't have a lawyer after
Sessions recusal that's just a funny
thing let me see if I can go fullscreen
with this that's just a funny thing
because it shows that once again Donald
Trump saw the Attorney General as his
lawyer and of course that's not the case
in reality in terms of how it's all
supposed to work but it certainly has
worked out that way and particularly it
has worked out that way
with the selection of William Barr who
has effectively effectively functioned
as Donald Trump's lawyer McGann refused
to participate in the Saturday night
massacre this is very interesting and
according to the report substantial
evidence supports the conclusion that
Trump ordered McGann to order Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein who
oversaw the Millar investigation
following sessions refusal to have the
special counsel removed McGann resisted
ordering Moeller's firing at trumps
behest in June of 2017
that's another attempt to obstruct this
is another attempt to obstruct and a
huge huge discovery revelation from the
Moller report Trump ordered Lewandowski
to get sessions to cover for him
two days after telling him again to fire
Moeller and end the investigation Trump
made another attempt to effect the
discord the course of the Russia
investigation according to the special
counsel report during a one-on-one
meeting with former campaign manager
Corey Lewandowski the president dictated
a message for him to give two sessions
the message that message sessions should
publicly announce that notwithstanding
his refusal from the Russia
investigation the investigation was very
unfair to the president and that the
president had done nothing wrong
which is an insane thing to request that
he say at another private meeting a
month later Trump asked Cory Lewandowski
about the message two sessions to limit
the Special Counsel investigation to
future election interference which
Lewandowski reassured Trump would be
delivered soon hours after that meeting
Trump lashed out at sessions in an
interview with the New York Times saying
that he would have selected another
attorney general if he had known
sessions would recuse himself
Lewandowski did not want to deliver the
president's message personally according
to the report so he asked senior White
House official Rick Dearborn to deliver
it Dearborn was uncomfortable with the
task and did not follow through the
special counsel notes another theme
people recognizing that many of Donald
Trump's attempts to obstruct our hugely
hugely problematic and refused to do
them
Trump's lawyers to Cohen stay on message
longtime Trump attorney Michael Cohen
who's serving three years in federal
prison on charges of tax fraud and lying
to federal investigators told the judge
in December that he had covered up the
president's dirty deeds according to the
special counsel report evidence exists
that Cohen's cover-ups were encouraged
by the president and his legal team who
Cohen alleges told him to stay on
message and not contradict Trump during
congressional testimony according to the
report
Trump's conduct towards Cohen changed
from praise when he falsely minimized
the president's involvement in the Trump
Tower Moscow project to castigation of
Cohen when he became a cooperating
witness once again this is what Michael
Cohen told us and this is corroborated
by the Special Counsel report again who
was lying
was it Cohen that was lying or not
it appears that Cohen was telling the
truth when he said that during his
congressional testimony let me do a
couple of other super chats as they come
in here comic book kid 2:10 has signed
up for a membership that is new member
number four of the evening we are
looking for 10 I also want to say hello
to we have one other new member here and
it just scrolled past Scott white scott
white is new member number five on our
website which gets us halfway there
ten memberships and I will open up the
phone lines we are currently at five
Elias that axis says report released
just before major holiday / weekend yeah
I don't normally I do look at that very
closely I mean I guess that the report
could have been held until Monday or
Tuesday but I don't know how much weight
I put into that I mean it is Thursday I
get that a lot of people are going away
tomorrow for either Easter or Passover I
don't know that it's that obvious in
this
Euler case that that was the idea that
the idea was to sort of take attention
away in that way and quite frankly the
snow job that has been done by William
bar and by everybody surrounding Trump
was so well executed for the trumpet
audience remember the left hasn't really
fallen for it but the right has that I
don't even think they needed to sort of
hide the report around Easter Passover
weekend James Buchi no says David do you
watch an I'm I'm kidding I'm kidding
David do you watch anime I don't the
only anime movie that I've ever seen
is spirited away I watched it years ago
I don't know how long I think it was on
an airplane and I liked it but no I
don't watch anime and I also read Akira
the graphic novel and it's not I mean I
don't dislike it it's not exactly my
thing I don't find it super compelling
mavis Leyva's says the amount the
moderators are too authoritarian you
can't even comment using all caps let me
take a look at what's going on here we
have moderators who are very very eager
let's see here I'm not seeing let's see
so message deleted
let's see what some of these deleted
messages are each shite and die yeah
okay that's a fair message to delete
that seems to make sense let's look at
other moderation that is taking place
someone was timed out for 30 seconds a
message was deleted the message was WTF
are you blabbering soy boy yeah it's in
all caps but I think if you sent that
message not in all caps it still would
have been timed out you're just trolling
let's look at another sample message
please people calm down
yeah you know I don't know that I would
time someone out merely for pudding
please people calm down in all caps
maybe we can change our policy on that I
don't think we need to time some some of
these all caps messages messages out
people saying limit the all caps PO
which makes sense uh what else do we
have here you know so far I'm pretty
happy with the moderation I have to say
although I think the all-caps message is
if it's just one line and they're not
trolling I think it's uh I think it's
okay let's see here what else did I want
to get to from the Muller report a
couple of other examples
Trump encouraged witnesses not to
cooperate so again we're in one of these
situations where we have to sort of
distinguish between a degree of evidence
that rises to the level of criminality
versus a degree of evidence that counts
towards the thing we believe the person
was trying to do the report makes it
abundantly clear that Donald Trump was
tampering with witnesses in trying to
get them not to cooperate but again the
detail is the report states no principle
of law excludes public acts from the
reach of the obstruction laws if the
likely effect of public acts is to
influence witnesses or alter their
testimony the harm to the justice
system's integrity is the same but the
special counsel contended that some
evidence supports a conclusion that the
president intended at least in part to
influence man affords jury but said that
alternative explanations for Trump's
comments including that he genuinely
felt sorry for man afford prevent a firm
contention that the president had a
corrupt intent behind this encouragement
for everybody who was saying all along
Moeller is a partisan actor against
Trump Moeller is in the pocket of the
Dems or whatever look at what it says
right there the benefit of the doubt was
given to Donald Trump the benefit of the
doubt was given to Donald Trump and
because Muller was able to sort of
concoct alternative reasons for which
Donald Trump might have been publicly
saying things about Paul Manafort the
decision was made
didn't rise to the level of criminality
this next part we basically know molar a
trump told Comey to kill the Flint
investigation we already knew that but
it's good to know that the molar report
corroborates public reporting about it
why molar didn't subpoena President
Trump this is extraordinarily disturbing
Trump's legal team was prepared to wage
a war to keep the president from being
subpoenaed into testifying under oath
before Robert Muller but the battle
never came molar never sought to legally
compel the president to testify the
special counsel writes that why lawyers
had determined that the special counsel
possesses both the authority and legal
justification to grand jury subpoena
Trump he declined in view of the
substantial delay that such an
investigative step would likely produce
at a late stage in our investigation it
wasn't convenient to subpoena Trump it
wasn't convenient to subpoena Trump and
what it led to is Donald Trump answering
all of these questions with he just
doesn't remember I have no recollection
I have no recollection I have no
recollection I have no specific
recollection I do not recall being aware
that is why we got these BS answers from
Donald Trump which investigators agreed
were inadequate
but Robert Moeller simply didn't want to
get into the legal process of these
subpoenas at the point at which he felt
was nearing the end of the investigation
absolutely disgusting absolutely
disgusting some evidence that Trump knew
of flynn's conversations with the
Russian ambassador again no evidence no
evidence no awareness no recollection
well there's evidence that Trump at
least knew that one person Michael Flynn
was having conversations with a Russian
ambassador so at every instance if you
actually look at the detail of this
report it almost doesn't matter because
they've already done such a great PR
campaign in selling exonerated selling
no collusion selling all of this
different stuff but if you look at the
detail some portion of almost every
allegation that was seriously made not
Trump personally colluded with Putin not
the PP tapes but all of the serious
allegations that we thought had merit
are backed by at least some evidence in
the Moller
or which is I don't even know the right
the right word to apply to it let me do
a couple of other super chats that are
coming in I want to say thanks to Dana
Eisenhower Dana Eisenhower has signed up
as a new member a david pakman.com slash
membership that's new member number six
if you want the phone lines opened we do
need four more members and pretty
quickly because i don't have unlimited
time for a stream tonight I see people
continuing to leave voicemails on the
phone line but it is not it is not yet
open for more members and I will open
that up did Muller make a political
decision by not being more aggressive in
regards to speaking with Trump yeah so I
actually just got to that and absolutely
David Atkins Esquire absolutely he did
and if you look at again if you look at
what he says here it was basically a
convenience thing and a political
decision that led to no subpoena for
Donald Trump and Trump getting out
getting away with these completely bogus
written answers where he simply doesn't
remember anything
Alf says Big D grandpa Sanders 2020 okay
a Bernie supporter in the audience
picturing my love David just wanted to
say hi David senpai yeah I don't even
know what that means but I think it is
another thing from manga or an I'm I'm
kidding I'm kidding please don't clip
that and make another viral video Doug
Condor Mr P you haven't talked about
note 4 Dom we did talk about it on our
members only bonus show there has been
so much news this week and I didn't
really have anything particularly
notable to add other than I've been to
Notre Dom several times I plan to visit
and maybe maybe still do plan to visit
the site in a couple of weeks when I am
back in France for a work project and we
did have an extensive conversation about
it on the members-only bonus show which
you would have access to if you remember
and which dennis kebab ik or kebab ik
now has access to as new member number
seven of the evening Dennis thank you so
much for signing
no coupon code for Dennis paying full
price really appreciate that but if you
want there are two coupon codes down in
the video description three more members
and I will open up the phone lines
another super chat from Ford 84-84 hey
new member question do you think it's
more likely in 2020 more progressives
get out to vote or convert independence
new member seven one six area code okay
so I don't know let's see Ford with Oh
Jason Ford okay did I miss okay Jason
Ford from seven one six I'll make a note
in case we get the phone lines open so
that Jason can call in I think that the
the the path of least resistance to
winning in 2020 is get people who are
already on our side to the polls okay
converting independence maybe converting
Trumpets waste of time
so I still think just getting
progressives to vote is the best
strategy John Mora comments on Neera
tanden Think Progress versus Bernie yeah
I addressed this yesterday actually
yesterday on the show we talked about
the New York Times article outlining and
sort of identifying uh well having to
adjust here
identifying near a tendon as one of the
people who's been going to these stop
Bernie meetings and I think it's vile
I've commented on it extensively already
so I won't do more but check out my
video from yesterday about it Brian
Ferren says Happy Passover thoughts on
Netanyahu re-election listen I have been
at speaking out against Benjamin
Netanyahu for I don't even remember how
many years at this point Benjamin
Netanyahu's presence as the Prime
Minister of Israel is completely toxic
there is no credible path to peace if
Benjamin Netanyahu is the president that
I I don't know how else I can say it and
thank you for the Passover wishes I will
be going to a seder on Saturday evening
and uh it will be probably pretty boring
like most satyrs but it is part of a
part of the tradition adjacent Braun
says hey David what do you think will
happen to dhaka I don't know what will
happen to Dhaka but I do not believe for
a second that Republic
Ekans are going to start deporting
people who came to the US as kids
illegally I just don't I think they
recognize that politically it's not
viable and that's it so I think this is
not legal advice of course but I think
that daca recipients are going to be
okay
mavis Leyva's says explain the logistics
of watching the David Pakman show as a
member you tube without ads yeah it's
very easy when you become a member and
you're logged in this member content
option appears at the top of the website
when you click that you get a whole
different section of the website which
has links to youtube videos that include
the full daily one-hour show with no ads
and the bonus show you can skip waiting
around for our individual clips to
publish each day it is what I would call
VIP treatment so log in click on member
content and you'll be good
Kent Iverson is a new YouTube member
that's you a new member number 8 of the
evening and Ian cross has signed up on
our website using the coupon code this
is 20/20 saving 40% that's new member
number 9 of the evening so we're just
one new member away listen here's my
last pitch of the evening because if we
don't make it we're not going to make it
the program mostly is funded by people
who say hey I'm gonna support you with a
few bucks a month I would love it if you
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership i believe that the normal
rates of six dollars a month or sixty
dollars a year are extraordinarily
reasonable for everything that you get
as a member and the amount of content we
produce but I get that that's a lot of
money for many people so we have
discounts available if you want to save
40 percent that'll drop the $6 to just
360 a month use the coupon code this is
20/20 if you want to get a yearly
membership for 25 bucks and be able to
renew it at that price for as long as
you want use the coupon code save 35 and
apply it to the $60 membership and
that'll get you a yearly membership for
25 bucks I know that most people most
people in the audience
afford two dollars and five cents a
month and it would really mean a lot to
me and it would really mean a lot to the
show if you signed up at any level that
one included Shane babaca love when I
see that babka of course one of my two
favorite desserts
do you still stay in touch with Luis yes
its ello UIs and I was just actually I
think I have a message from him right
now he is like a week late on our former
congressman Richard Neal supporting a
bill to prevent the government from
doing free tax filing software online
and I said to Louis yeah I covered it
last week and he's all confused about it
and I sent him the link and yeah
everything's fine with Louis I keep in
touch with him and I'm gonna be seeing
him this weekend Passover weekend we
will I will be seeing Louis and he is he
has an exciting trip coming up actually
which I guess I shouldn't talk about
only because maybe he doesn't want
people knowing where he's going he could
get mobbed by the fans but he has a very
interesting trip coming up and maybe
he'll Skype in from it although the time
difference this is a hint
the time difference will make it
difficult Ella Mae is a new member on
YouTube but using the join button down
below thank you very much for signing up
carpe Donnelly says Muller's revelation
that russia funded several rallies to
show additional to so additional descent
is that not the most concerning part
moving forward I'm glad you're bringing
that up I'm gonna make a note of that I
haven't seen that yet again it's 448
pages and I've not gone through all of
it so I will make a note of that and and
check that out that would be
extraordinarily disturbing okay we've
gotten 10 new members so let's open up
the phone lines a little bit 6 1 7 8 3 0
4 7 5 0 47 50 that's the phone number 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I'm going to take a few
phone calls from people in the audience
if you want to expedite your way on
become a member and include your area
code in the first or last name field so
that I know that it is you
and that will get you thank you for
calling that will get you to the front
of the line otherwise six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty and
you may have to wait a little bit let me
get my notes here so I can we we put
every caller and caller ID with very
specific notes about how their
connection was and how everything is
going so I'm going to keep an eye on
that
thanks to Rob Brady Rob Brady has signed
up on our website uh and a huge huge
super chat from Khalil Ahmadi two
hundred Danish kroner I actually don't
know how much that is in u.s. dollars I
think u / u /
Tanner d / 4 I think it might have been
10 I was in Copenhagen recently I think
it was sandwiches that were 200 Danish
kroner I think were 20 bucks yeah I
think that's right some say there will
need to be a ubi in place in the future
do you agree and if if so when also
speaking of Notre Dame Ubisoft giving
away unlimited copies of AC unity in
respect of the incident yeah I mean
listen we need to re-examine our
relationship to work that period that's
the only things are changing for Homo
sapiens in the industrialized world and
I think at a certain point there is
going to need to be something that is
not means-tested that says if you're
doing the type of work that's not
normally well compensated in the market
if you're doing creative work if you're
doing social entrepreneurship type work
that may not be well compensated you
still deserve to have an okay life so I
think eventually we will need that and I
would say probably within the next seven
to ten years okay let's go to the phone
line 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 thanks to Corey
Smoot who has signed up if you want to
get right on the phone with me include
your area code when you call in that way
I know that you are a new member
let's first go to our caller from the I
can't tell if this is country code 18 or
area code 8 6 5 who's this
hey there's Brian hey Brian where you
calling from porn from Knoxville okay
alright is that is it area
code 865 is that what's going on it
isn't it actually spells out ball for
the volunteers oh alright well
congratulations well thank you um my
question is and I came up with this
because I didn't know there was this
whole stop burning movement right and
I'm I guess my question to you I am a
Bernie supporter there's some other
decent candidates out there now but as a
Bernie supporter I'll probably support
the Democratic candidate but I don't
like what I'm already hearing the
Democratic establishment is doing sure
but what can we do to be positive when
we hear these negative things out there
when you hear negative things about
Bernie or when you hear that there is an
establishment movement developing
against Bernie the latter oh okay okay
so you need to make your voice heard so
it needs to be exposed that this
movement is starting and I'm not even
decided yet that I'm I'm supporting
Bernie in the primary I'm gonna be
making my decision soon but I'm against
any movement that is establishment
Democrats trying to stop Bernie so what
I'm doing is I'm telling people that
it's going on if we expose it at every
at every opportunity that's one aspect
of it the DNC claims already they've
claimed that they're not going to metal
but DNC a Democratic Party higher-ups
are already getting involved so we just
need to keep exposing it at every
opportunity and that's what I plan to do
thanks that's why I'm gonna keep the
positive attitude maybe support Bernie
but it might not work now but that might
change right there all right thanks very
much great to hear from you let's see
let's go next - lets go - I believe it's
Josiah is this Josiah uh hey David
uh oh it is you you've got a atrocious
connection today Josiah uh can you hear
me any better yeah that is better I'm
sorry I was on speakerphone oh he's okay
just a little question because I've been
recently having talks with one of my
older friends is an old school Democrat
uh it it seems like I'm watching him
turn to the right in real time because
last time I talked to him he outright
told me that my generation is gonna have
to fix this by
our selves and this time around he's
starting to spout some of the right-wing
one-liners that you hear about you know
men being pushed off to the side and I
was wondering like how would I try and
keep them to the you know truth well I
I've said this before my general advice
is that these sort of aggressive
argumentation techniques and just
showing people facts rarely particularly
when they're like attracted to the sort
of atmosphere of an ideology or movement
rather than the specifics it's like the
facts don't really matter as a general
thing I think it's useful to ask
questions about how they came to the
conclusions that they're coming to ask
questions you try to get them to defend
with facts their position rather than
giving counter facts ask them to defend
their positions with facts and ask what
it is that would change their mind
hypothetically and that I think is one
of the more effective ways to get
conversations going that can ultimately
change people's minds now when it comes
to Bernie Sanders cuz he recently had
like a few huge slam dunks one of the
things I began wondering US should he
drop running as president and become
someone's VP because after Trump whoever
becomes president is gonna have to spend
a lot of time rekindling our
relationships overseas like do you think
he should become VP so he can govern and
actually do stuff from the background
why but so can he do it as president as
well hmm no this was just an idea I've
heard like I'm other people floating
towards me and since I don't know what
know about it as much as I would like to
I was wondering if like he would have an
ID on it no I mean Bernie's leading the
polls right now so I don't know why he
would say I'm gonna just jump out and be
someone's vice president that doesn't
make sense to me all right thank you for
answering my question all right very
good appreciate the call we're taking
phone calls right now at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 we have a whole bunch of people
holding but I have a little secret if
you want to get on with me right away
you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership and when you sign up
include your area code in the first or
last name field
in addition
your name because then when your new
membership comes in I'll see your area
code and then I will immediately go to
you if you call it okay so it's sort of
like expedited get on the phone
sign up include your area code and then
I will get directly to you which is very
very exciting let's go to our caller
from the eight one three area code who's
calling today from eight one three eight
one three I can sort of hear some
background noise I think that's that's
you there this is Ashley hey Ashley
how are you doing good um had a quick
question I've been asking different
people that I could get in touch with
people just friends I don't want to
exceed on that census I have to go in a
minute but I was wondering if you had a
particular strategy how to defeat
incense if it's possible the right-wing
propaganda machine that we see in place
which Fox News is something out
xenophobic anti-immigrant nonsense 24/7
[Music]
is it enough to penetrate that level of
people inculcated within those beliefs
or to move forward as a society with a
president on the left are we going to
have to dismantle this system entirely I
kind of don't see a way forward without
doing this and I was curious to get your
opinion I don't think you have to
dismantle the entire system net
neutrality and Internet freedom is a
huge part of this counter-programming is
a huge part of this and quite frankly
not two not two
you know the david pakman show by itself
is not the solution to this problem but
if as a if has a progressive movement we
understand that we unfold and the
channels just by having cable
subscriptions then we have to say let's
actually support the counter programming
let's support programs like the david
pakman show or whatever program is
important to you because it's you can't
simultaneously want to pierce the bubble
created by these channels and not
financially support the alternatives so
I think that that counter programming is
one of the biggest things and we've got
a fight for net neutrality that seems
totally sure I definitely support both
those things a lot of have longer
conversations and have more time I guess
I would have more questions about
systemically how we would tackle that
beyond net neutrality beyond cutting the
cord etc right thank you for answering
my question David thank you yeah and I
don't want to take up too much more of
your time I know it's busy over there so
I'll let you go Ashley from st. Pete
great to hear from you Ford 84-84 is
asking what's the phone number again the
phone number for phone calls is six one
seven eight three zero 47:56 one seven
eight three zero
4750 Jimmy from Philly the angry Trump
Astana I'm going to go to the chat to
see if I should talk to him
some people love hearing from him others
are sick of Jimmy from Philly so I'm
gonna leave it up to the chat because I
could hear from him or not it's it's
sort of I I don't I don't really care
one way or the other he calls and leaves
voicemails all the time we have a no we
have a no skip don't waste your time no
no no no no yes Jimmy no yes yes yes yes
no no yes no yes
skip yes yes yes no no no okay
I am having a hard time figuring out
exactly whether the yeses or the noes
are winning so what I'll do is if when
Jimmy gets to the top of the queue
because there are people who have been
waiting longer if I'm still taking phone
calls I will talk to him
let's see Val from Agawam is on the
phone what's going on Val hi David how
are you doing good how you doing good
you can hear me okay
you know about your connection as
pristine as always oh great that that is
my goal thank you so much for that
outstanding coverage of the Bernie Foxx
Town Hall I really appreciated you doing
that my pleasure I agree with your
assessment completely that he absolutely
dominated in a way that I had not seen
before
absolutely um I was wondering did you
hear that Joe Biden was in Boston today
no I did not what was he doing
supposedly he was supporting a union
that's on strike stop and shop I don't
know if you've heard but yeah many of
his laughing shops are unafraid this is
the craziest thing my mom's affecting me
personally actually yeah yeah my mom who
lives out in western Massachusetts she
called me yesterday and she said she had
no idea what was going on that there's a
strike the the workers at Stop and Shop
are striking she went to one of the
stopping shops and she went in such [ __ ]
no idea what's going on she saw protest
was going on outside just went inside
and she was effectively strike breaking
she was she was crossing the picket line
without even knowing and she's a huge
Union supporter and she just got like an
eerie feeling because there were no
customers or employees or products
inside of stommer right and she ended up
leaving and then she called me I said
mom what are you doing
what do you would you you're you're
breaking the picket line you're crossing
the picket line and then she said yeah
well it was just so bad in there that I
ended up going somewhere else and she is
now supporting the striking workers at
Stop and Shop
oh well good I really appreciate that
yeah absolutely a lot now that's
interesting that job I didn't realize
Joe Biden was keyed into that and that's
that's interesting
yes actually I know somebody in my
family works for stopping shop and is
greatly affected by this and he received
a text that Biden was in Boston
fascinating I didn't even know well you
know I guess I didn't know there are
stopping shops in Boston yeah well
that's all it's good stuff we'll see how
it ends up and see what they get now I
think it's important I don't want to but
I know you know Val what the other big
supermarket chain is in western mass
let's not mention it but knows I won't
there's a different supermarket chain in
Western Massachusetts that a lot of
people are saying I'm supporting the
striking workers at Stop & Shop I'm
going to the other chain the other chain
that's very anti-union for like 20 years
oh my gosh so you know I don't it's six
of one half dozen to the other in some
way Wow yeah yeah well thank you for
taking my call it's always great to talk
to you um Happy Passover to you and your
family hope it's not boring hope it's
fun thank you very much yes I will be
having bitter herbs before you know it
valve from a go I'm always great to hear
from you and are you on a landline by
the way because the connection is just
so good no this is my cell so incredible
incredible all right Val great to hear
from you thank you very much let's see
we got a question about Argentinian food
recipes yeah there's I mean there's just
so many I don't I wouldn't even know
what to tell you the Argentinian
equivalent I listen most of all most
Argentinian recipes are modified from
some other cuisine either Italian or
French in most cases I'll do an
Argentine Argentinian Food Show at some
point and thanks to CCL who has sent a
$5 Super chat okay one of our new
members is calling in from the seven one
six seven one six you're on the air
remind me of which new member this was
was this Sean seven one six are you
there okay Jason Jason what's going on
Jason thanks for your support yeah yeah
absolutely where you calling from yeah
okay I'm watching you right now on
YouTube there's kind of like an echo
delay effect there yeah all you've got
to do is mute your phone or our computer
so that you just hear me on the phone
that's the way to do
yeah well first of all let's want to say
Big Show I got into you after
kolinsky and watch since their talk and
I got into you
okay listen before we go further turn
down whatever you're using to listen to
the stream you got to turn that down and
then it'll solve the echo problem oh
okay yeah
yeah oh yeah I guess man okay yeah see
ya
I wouldn't ask you a question about you
know I'm kind of hopeless man here like
and trying to convert any type of
Trumpets yeah
at the same time I'm hopeless with
getting outcome vote I mean you know
progressives are still come up though
you know that's that's the issue and
there's this dogmatic personality with
Trump now yep it's so strong that like
late what do you think about like how do
we burst that bubble cuz clearly like
you can't I mean Bernie did a good job
with uh you know Town Hall but you know
that's not gonna get through to enough
people listen here's the thing I don't
think we should waste any time trying to
so okay at the at the national level
Bernie's offered an hour on Fox News
take it take it he impressed a whole
bunch of people at the individual level
I just wouldn't waste my time trying to
convince Trump is we don't need to
convince a single trumpet in order to
win in 2020 we just need to get out five
percent more of the vote in key swing
states like that's it that the recipe is
very simple doesn't mean it's easy but
it is very simple and I would not waste
my time trying to convert trumpets or at
the at the one-on-one level pierce their
bubble it's a waste of time right now
yeah and I agree with that I agree with
like the people that are there are too
far gone if you will but the people that
you know essentially got him elected you
know the people in those three states
right like 80,000 people or whatever the
number is vaguely those people we need
to convince that's that's what I'm
worried about like how do we convince
them you know you sing the people that
go over Trump in from those three he
states yeah we don't need to convince
them we just got to get turnout up like
five percent and then we went yeah but I
don't know I'm kind of pessimistic about
the turnout if you're promise for yeah
if you're if you're pessimistic about
the turnout have you ever tried to
convince a Trump is to see logic and
reason I'd be more pessimistic about the
success chance of that yeah yeah yeah
that's true yeah I don't know I mean you
know we get older said I'm with the same
age around the same age as you I
yeah I might I don't really focus on the
18 year olds and how enthusiastic they
are about voting now I mean hopefully
they come out you know I mean I just
come on I mean people like sam cedars
age or not like progressive yeah here
are say what I'm saying yes Taylor the
get out the vote to people that are on
our side we're not trying to get the
vote out from people who aren't
progressive just there's plenty of
progressives around who agree with
progressive ideas we just got a lot of
no hey there's people that that you can
vote for Jason thank you so much I call
and really she ate yours appreciate it
thank you see CL sends a super chat
thank you for promoting critical
thinking we appreciate your hard work
honesty integrity and critical thinking
thank you PS keep up the excellent work
let's go to the nine five six
area code who's calling today from 956
from Edinburgh Texas right very good to
hear from you I appreciate the call yeah
thank you you know thank you for
covering Bernie and I'm looking forward
to your coverage on the beauty report
and what can happen from it absolutely
what's uh what's wrong
all right so I work in finance and I
would I lean very much progressive right
and I'm a huge brainy founder supporter
but with the free college right and this
is just my idea and I'd like you to
maybe like push back on it okay but I
don't believe there should be free
college for everyone I believe that
there should be for as America to
compete with the rest of the world there
should be free college for certain
majors and specialties that actually we
need and we lack you know such as like
the stem field engineers you know
finance majors accountants coding
cybersecurity I find it really hard for
me to pay for someone's you know a
liberal arts degree when they're gonna
graduate into a saturated job market and
not be able to find a job and to like
you know for us to get a return on
investment because it is a tax payers
fitting the bill what do you think okay
so let's take it into two different sort
of ideas the first idea is that we
should be encouraging we should be
incentivizing people to make certain
career choices on the basis of what's
necessary and beneficial and in-demand
completely agree with you however
remember we're talking only about public
colleges and universities we're talking
depending on which plan you look at
we're talking about just tuition which
is just one component of what college
costs and when you still have to get in
okay so we're not the idea that there's
going to be a radical sort of over
utilization of college if it's free yeah
I mean enrollment at state colleges and
universities may go up but it can only
go up to the extent that the colleges
have capacity for that and you still
have to get in and colleges have
entrance requirements and it's not just
like Community College where you sign up
and get in so I think the issue that
you're saying you're worried about is
just not nearly as big of an issue as
you're making it out to be but beyond
that I don't have a problem figuring out
ways for government to incentivize
people to go into particular fields I
just don't know that saying free college
only in certain industries make sense
because
a lot of those other career paths have
significant societal value that may not
be as in-demand in industry in the same
way so I don't know that I would do it
the exact way you're suggesting but I'm
completely up for incentivizing people
to take to make career decisions that
are based on on the degree of demand for
those positions for sure psychology and
like don't work within that field but
you know we were to invest into certain
infrastructures and like public health
and mental health those people can find
jobs later down the line it's more so
it's like you know the saturation of the
job market but I do agree with you that
not everybody gets in and you have to
meet a certain level I just want to get
your take on it yep yeah I mean I
incentivize away I just wouldn't start
doing you know the other issue with that
is that you're going to there are all
sorts of different demographic lines and
socio-cultural lines among which people
choose majors and concentrations and the
last thing we want to do is to end up
creating sort of categories of
concentrations that are going to further
increase some of those demographic
inequalities and that's what you may end
up with if you start kind of picking and
choosing who gets to go for free and who
doesn't because there are there's what
there's many other factors that sort of
determine what paths are interesting to
people and we wouldn't want to be
discriminatory in any way I definitely
would agree with that I mean I guess
there are some social economical effects
that come in to where people fall into
more of an issue so you don't have
internet and how he can't be expect you
to learn how to code or take a job like
that so definitely see where your thing
and and ask you just a comment I live
here on the southern border one of the
safest places in the world I love it and
thank you for taking my call all right
and it sounds like you put us on
speakerphone at the end there a little
going-away gift very very much
appreciate the phone call he thought I
wasn't gonna notice and of course
everybody in the chat very very clearly
noticed okay that does it for me tonight
I'm sorry to everybody I didn't get to
including people who wanted to hear from
Jimmy from Philly congratulations to
people who didn't but we are just out of
time
there will be another livestream before
you know it